A classic example of machine learning project is what we already know
spam filter
we already experience
some of these things on the social media platform on our emails
streaming platforms and the likes
when we look at some of these platforms
what they really do is there's a model that gets better every day
now with this model there are couple of things that happen
in the first instance when those models were trained
they may be trained with maybe like hundred or 500,000 keywords
for example you want to dictate if an email is spam or not
things you're gonna put out there could be um
maybe purchase now or subscribe now
some keywords that you know that some spammers oftentimes use
but one thing that is very constant is that people get creative
when they know that your machine detects certain keywords
they change it now
how does your computer or your machine
really knows that some of these guys are changing this terminology
you can achieve that through machine learning through machine learning
you define the rules the model wants
what the machine gets to do at the end of the day
is it learns from people's interaction
so imagine if there's a new keyword that they've introduced
and you're not even aware of it
and maybe the customers get to report those words
often what the machine will do
or what the model will do
because of the new available data
is to think of the repercussion
or the repetitive aspect of what the people are reporting
update that list by itself
and when a spammer sends something
the next time it will flag it without actually getting to the user
so that's typically how machine learning works